fünf Tage lang wurde abgestimmt in den
vier von Russland besetzten Gebieten in
der Ukraine die scheinreferenten in
luhans godonjesk herrson und saporicia
und auch wenn das Resultat von
vornherein feststand jetzt kommt der
Kreml mit den angeblichen Ergebnissen so
und Überraschung eine Mehrheit ist für
den Beitritt zu Russland mehr als 97%
aus diesen Gebieten jetzt stimmt noch
das russische Parlament über die
Aufnahme der Regionen ab hier ist ja
eigentlich schon klar wie das Ergebnis
aussehen wird und dann ist die Annexion
durch dann sind die ukrainischen
Regionen zumindest für den Kreml
russisches Staatsgebiet
wir werden handeln um unser Folgen der
Region hersong in der Region saporicia
in Don Bass in den derzeit besetzten
Gebieten der Region haakev und auf der
Krim zu schützen diese Phase in den
besetzten Gebieten kann man nicht einmal
als Nachahmung von Referenten bezeichnen
wir wussten im voraus was das Ergebnis
sein würde nicht einmal die
Geheimdienste musste sich besonders
anstrengen die vereinbarten Zahlen für
diese Fahrt wurden an die Medien
weitergegeben Russland verbirgt dies
nicht einmal die einzig vernünftige
Antwort auf diese Dreistigkeit des
Besatzers ist noch mehr Unterstützung
für die Ukraine und ich bin unseren
Partnern dankbar die diese Unterstützung
bestätigen Verteidigung Finanzen
Sanktionen
uns zugeschaltet ist jetzt bild-vize
Paul Ronzheimer live aus Kiew Paul
selensky sagt er könne sich weiter auf
die Unterstützung des Westens verlassen
trotzdem die Frage an dich befürchten
die Ukraine eine weitere Eskalation
für die Ukraine ist jeden Tag eine große
Eskalation jeden Tag sterben hunderte
Soldaten an den verschiedenen
Frontlinien die 2000 Kilometer fast lang
sind aber ja man erwartet dass es hier
in den nächsten Tagen weiter explodieren
kann denn die Gerüchte die Spekulation
besagen das Wladimir Putin
möglicherweise schon am Freitag in einer
Rede an die Nation in einer Ansprache an
die Nation diese fake-referenten das
muss man immer wieder sagen das ist fake
Referenten sind
anerkennen will und dann sagen will dass
diese Gebiete jetzt russisch sein und
dann das ist auch die Vermutung hier
erwartet man eine Eskalation dann
erwartet man dass Wladimir Putin
möglicherweise noch heftiger reagieren
könnte auf diese Frontabschnitte und
sagen wird hier verteidigen wir jetzt
diesen vermeintlich russischen Boden was
hörst du aus den Regionen gibt es
überhaupt realistische Berichte aus den
Referendum Regionen glaubhafte Berichte
von den Menschen also dort
es gibt immer noch Menschen die aus
diesen Regionen fliehen es gibt Berichte
von unabhängigen Aktivisten es gibt
Berichte auch von Leuten mit denen wir
in Kontakt standen die raus sind und
dann wieder rein sind und da hören wir
das natürlich die Menschen mehr oder
weniger ja mit der Waffe im Anschlag
dort zu diesen Abstimmungen gezwungen
wurden das gesagt wurde ihr müsst
abstimmen und das dann natürlich eine
vermeintlich freie Abstimmung überhaupt
nicht möglich ist und dass diese Zahlen
also dass diese 98 Prozent 97 Prozent
dass das natürlich alles schon vor Fest
statt
vielen Dank Paul Ronzheimer live aus der
Ukraine
[Musik]